let's go this is exciting oh my gosh
we're in France this is crazy
right it's good to see Evan was um happy
and enjoying
this in this little town yeah we gotta
get in shape I'm already tired we made
it this was good yeah frustrations but
we made it we handle we do difficult
things let's go we got lost and then we
uh offend someone a fan of the channel
stop me for a selfie and I said happy to
do this healthy and then can you tell us
where we're going
and he told us where to go and I think
we're on the right path party
good morning Evan Carmichael are you
ready are you ready this is it this is
it the official start of the trip did
you see basically how are you how did
you sleep last night
I slept for I was sleeping for 10 hours
okay that's in bed for like 12 hours my
back hurts it was not a great bed but it
was nice to get some sleep Ah that's
good they're not sleeping for two days
yeah and uh we are going to monster
Michelle we're going to The Abbey we are
we have the first ticket says it opens
up and then we're gonna explore the
island a little bit it's only kilometers
a pretty small island check out and then
go back to Paris
but let's start I'm excited we came here
last night so now we get to see it with
the lights on yeah the lights on with
the sky on no the sun it doesn't matter
my mind is not quite there yet but I'm
ready to go let's go
[Music]
all right they open
now we're gonna go up
and then you're gonna go first because
you have to take it true yeah
the stairs guys we gotta get in shape
I'm tired
we're here you ready I'm ready I'm tired
let's go I'm tired
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh we have to be very quiet so I'm not
gonna do much talking okay I'm just
gonna show you guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
we actually went to the Run exit so we
climbed the whole thing again and then
exit here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
at the same time because otherwise I'd
be tripping down
[Music]
[Music]
we were the first to out what do you
think Evan we were the first to get out
yeah oh yeah it's fine yeah we saw we
need to see you enjoyed yeah my back is
so sweaty good I work out for the for
the month no no that's
okay for the day yeah
it's good okay what's next next we gotta
maybe look a little bit around the town
we're gonna check out yeah and then
we're gonna head to Paris all right
party
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Place pick up two cappuccino yeah and
then one croissant and one chocolate
Danish
try it first coffee
okay just eat the chocolate
Danish
okay
[Music]
all right we packed that we're gonna
drop off the the key the room key to to
the hotel and then we're gonna head out
to Paris
[Music]
all right done we're gonna go back pick
up the car
and head our way to
um Paris thank you come on say Michelle
for the for the hospitality it was a
night
it was a what a night I actually did not
sleep that well anyways Evan have fun
yeah it's nice to see it's good to see
Evan was um happy and enjoying
this in this little town yeah
okay let's go
thank you
[Music]
we stopped to get gas and stretch our
legs a little bit and then go get some
coffee maybe
it's still a bathroom I fell asleep a
little bit you did it yeah
didn't feel didn't feel relaxed no
didn't feel arrested also
foreign
the whole way it's just been let's go
this is exciting oh my gosh we're in
France this is crazy
right
yeah I've been so tired it's like
stoning out trying to pass out but I
can't really pass out because it's so
Sunny the sun you can you see this the
sun is shining on you Nina the sun loves
you it means the world loves you
thanks for the compliment
okay okay let's go I'm out of the way
[Music]
so it was a struggle to find the um the
return for the car but anyhow we made a
couple mistakes a couple wrong turns
it's the best but but it's okay if we
made it returned a car now we're gonna
find Nina was very helpful navigate now
we're gonna find the the the the the the
navigation no to find the train to take
to our hotel
foreign
[Music]
stopped me for a selfie
and I said happy this healthy and then
can you tell us where we're going
and he told us where to go and I think
we're on the right path fingers crossed
we are doing it this is part of the
adventure three stops three stops
[Music]
[ __ ]
foreign
this is the hotel we're gonna stay in
[Music]
[Music]
excited for the hotel room
drop off our luggage we made it this was
good yeah frustrations but we made it we
handled we do difficult things let's go
yeah but there's some frustration in
between that's okay it's not really okay
[Music]
this is our hotel room
and here comes
Evan Carmichael
there's a Nina wow that this place just
got much better if it comes to the
built-in you know what is this is like a
whole
sweet area yeah cool on them bedroom a
king size bed is hard to get in downtown
Paris so okay excited about that yeah
okay guys oh there's another TV here oh
wow oh there's another two bathrooms wow
look at the sink you get your own thing
I get my own sink
wow okay just don't get in my way okay
go yeah good job Batman
if I ever found this do we stay at the
hotel a little bit I I shower look at my
puffy here to see your face okay okay
now we're gonna go out and meet one of
the movement maker members Mina for
dinner yeah
you know where you're going
okay
[Music]
what are you gonna start first
okay try it
Nina's going for the snail
here it comes here it comes okay I don't
know how to use this and
there it is
[Music]
would you say goodbye behind look at
that there you go hey wow look at that
we just said goodbye to Mina and we're
just gonna go home and relax I was
actually very tired Nina hasn't slept
yeah I had I had 10 hours of sleep last
night and I got four so yeah so I need
to I need to I needed to sleep we've got
a big day head tomorrow yeah
okay so let's go home well go to back to
the hotel
good morning Paris good morning Nina
where are we going today I don't know
you don't know oh I like your outfit
it's great it's amazing we're twins uh
we are going to the Louvre today
and we're going to Notre Dame today and
we're going to the pantheon today
and that's a lot